i want to talk to you about the strategy
how you did it what a rent to rent is
what a lease option agreement is what
service accommodation is how you did it
what area you've done it in and i really
want to go through the a to z so that
people watching this maybe can
skip some of the hardships on youtube
they can copy it paste it and do the
same watching the video so first things
first
um rent to rent that was your first deal
yeah first deal how did you find it
what happened
so the rent to rent initially i spent a
lot of time phoning agents getting
rejected hello we don't know what a
company that is we don't know what rent
to rent is leave us alone firm down i
was like oh picked up the phone again
and just kept going and going and going
and going
and
i had to go for no
every time what does that mean what does
go for no means so don't expect
yes don't expect them to buy oh yes we
do do company likes corporate let's rent
to rent
don't expect that um and just keep
ringing the phone the more times you're
in the phone the more likely you are to
get right but that's a really big lesson
straight away rather than ringing up and
thinking i hope they say yes i hope they
say yes it says and then they say no you
go oh rejected and then you quit yeah if
you think actually they probably will
say now and guess what that's part of
the game hey
my name's tom da la la la la
i'm looking to rent this property it
would be a corporate letter i wouldn't
be living there myself and if they go
whoa we don't do corporate let's
you go well i expected that to happen
anyway yeah and then you pick up the
phone again and then you pick up the
phone again so how many how many people
did you speak to before you had someone
that said yeah i'm open
i must have made about 20 phone calls
20 30 phone calls before i got a yes
rejection rejection rejection rejection
what was it that kept me going through
the rejections
knowing that
if i did keep ringing and i've followed
kind of
scripts or maybe what i'd seen on videos
that you done and how to talk to the
agents make sure you said the right
things because that's really important
if you kind of pick up the firm without
any confidence not knowing exactly what
you're gonna say and kind of wing it
if you've not done it before it's really
hard to get that conversation going yeah
so
picking up the phone knowing what to say
being polite with confidence
um
expecting nur and then obviously
eventually after the 30 calls i got a
yes which was fantastic amazing so that
first agent that was like yes this is
something we're open to um you're based
where huddersfield you're based in
huddersfield and you're trying to
convince me that huddersfield is a great
holiday destination
i'm not sure about that one still
huddersfield or hawaii i'm not sure but
we'll get there so this first house in
huddersfield yeah um what was it what
was it currently being used as so it was
currently just being used as a single
letter it was advertised as two bedrooms
but it had a reception room and a loft
right so they had the floor plan um on
their website and i thought well that's
easily one two that's four rooms
yes so um how do you turn a sitting room
into a bedroom put a bed in it yes
so you see this two bedroom for rent how
much was it on for rent uh 575 pounds a
month five seven five and you're
thinking well hold on a minute all right
rooms are renting for like 400 pound a
month i could rent both rooms out and
the sitting room and the loft and i
could get about what hundred fifteen
hundred pounds it yeah that's how much i
mean i'm gonna pay the landlord i'm
gonna pay the bills i'll be left with a
ka-ching some nice passive income for me
550 a month profit so that profits you
550 a month yep setting it up i mean
dude man i came out to the house i've
seen the house
you had to paint it yourself yeah you
had to furnish it how much money did you
have to put to get that property
um so i didn't actually pay a deposit on
the property how did you get how did you
get around that
uh
sweet talking kind of i just kind of
said well
um it's great as it is but this is as a
single let but this is what i want to do
i'm gonna have to need to paint i'm
gonna have to need to put in furniture
in four rooms which isn't cheap i'm
gonna have to get a carpet putting in
the loft
um and then they i was kind of like well
come on then and then they were like
yeah go for it and then um i had to pay
575 um the day that i signed so
yep up front um and then the furnishings
uh for the beds um and the bedside
tables that was all ikea
and the carpets and then i painted
myself i started to buy the pen and the
paint brushes and stuff yeah so
cost around 600 pounds all of that yeah
the rent up front five seven fives uh
you're looking at just over a grand
that's not a lot though no no it's not
because it made itself back in two
months so just over a grand
but you had to put some sweat equity in
it because you did a lot of the stuff
yourself yeah um
however
so talk me through the figures fifteen
hundred pound how how long did it take
to fill the rooms
um
not long at all uh maybe
two weeks from when i got the keys two
weeks i know your mom was a little bit
stressed yeah because she was like oh
you've just gone on ranger needs his
course and now you've
rented this house what was if you can't
write the rules
yeah what does your mom think uh so
she's quite um an old-fashioned landlady
uh she's um her and my dad have done
pretty well in profit but only really
buying uh properties and renting them
out just single lets you got a few hmrs
um but she'd never heard of the concept
of rent to rent so i told all about i
watched i've been on samuel lee's online
crash course i've looked at some of the
videos this is like a really good idea
for someone my age that doesn't have a
lot of money or experience
i can you know make a few hundred pounds
a month and i'll also get the experience
of being a landlord
and she was like oh well i've never
heard of this i've been doing this for
18 20 years i've got no idea what this
is are you sure are you sure and i was
like yeah yeah we'll figure it out yeah
did she give you money to get started no
nothing nothing at all so all right so
you was a little bit skeptical
you started yourself yeah you put your
own money in yeah from just little side
jobs and stuff while you were studying
you also
do this property did you rent the rooms
yourself
yes
them all myself on uh open rent spare
room and facebook marketplace cool which
is basic next to nothing
that's completely free completely free
so you marketed the rooms you filled
them single-handedly yeah you're then
getting a profit of like about 500
something pounds a month what did you
think when you got that first property
the money started coming in
um
like i said i kind of have to pinch
myself a little bit like um
i've never really heard of any other 18
year old landlords yeah like people were
paying me money
to
have a roof over their head and i was
kind of like this is not this i was like
a year ago this is not the service that
i think i'd be providing for people yeah
um and then when i started seeing the
money coming in i was like well
where's the next one yeah
now you used the money you reinvested it
you've done um you know you've done
quite a bit training with myself yes uh
how's the training been by the way it's
been fantastic uh everything's been
um so informative and to
every dotted every i crossed every t all
the details
um and without the training i wouldn't
be where i am now i wouldn't be sat here
if it wasn't for the training i wouldn't
be financially free
um i wouldn't be able to kind of almost
do what i want when i want now kind of
thing yeah so i'm really grateful for
that oh well thank you for saying and
it's it for me it's it's a great buzz
being able because when i started out i
was 17 i got my first house at 17 and
you know being able to see other young
people win it's it's awesome